[Musica]
il conto alla rovescia verso il 2030 e
il 2050 due delle date importanti a tema
ambiente è già iniziato e da un bel po'
di tempo da ex giocatore di
pallacanestro ho una certa abitudine con
i Conte all rovesci una partita di
pallacanestro in Europa dura 40 minuti
ognuno dei quattro periodi 10 minuti e
abbiamo a disposizione 24 Secondi per
fare canestro e il tempo ogni volta va
verso lo zero proprio come nei film
quando l'ordin sta per esplodere in
campo si sente si percepisce la tensione
la pressione quando la Il tempo va verso
la sirena finale statisticamente una
palla persa un tiro sbagliato a inizio
partita ha lo stesso identico valore di
una palla pera vera un tiro sbagliato a
un minuto dalla fine statisticamente
però se sbaglio un tiro a 30 secondi
dalla fine col punteggio in parità o
commetto una palla persa a 5 secondi
dalla fine sotto di un punto ci sarà
qualcuno che arriva e mi dice Teo non ti
preoccupare Hai sbagliato un tiro anche
nel primo tempo è la stessa cosa Non è
vero non è per niente la stessa cosa
perché il peso specifico di ogni singolo
gesto tiro palla persa è decisamente
diverso semplicemente perché più ci
avviciniamo alla Sirena finale meno
tempo abbiamo per recuperare da
quell'errore
nella Pall canestro c'è un frangente
della partita a cui viene addirittura
dato un nome Clutch i minuti in the
Clutch sono gli ultimi cin di un
incontro quando il punteggio la
differenza di punteggio tra le due
squadre è al massimo di C punti i
giocatori Clutch sono quelli che in quei
frangenti Per capacità e caratteristiche
riescono a fare la differenza
vi faccio qualche nome che anche se non
siete appassionati di pallacanestro e
Vergognatevi
conoscete LeBron James steph curry luuka
doncic giocatori meravigliosi per
talento per tecnica personalità questi
giocatori ma in generale tutti i
giocatori in quei frangenti hanno
percentuali al tiro peggiori rispetto
alle loro abitudini è un dato di fatto e
statistica proprio nello sport e nella
pallacanestro dobbiamo affrontare due
elementi il tempo inteso anche come età
che avanza e un avversario che a volte
può essere più forte di noi la razza
umana a tema Ambiente ha gli stessi due
elementi da sfidare il tempo appunto che
è sempre di meno e un avversario che in
questo caso però siamo
noi è quel piccolo margine di errore che
ci deve far percepire quel senso di
urgenza in quello che facciamo quel
senso di esigenza verso noi stessi e
verso chi abbiamo accanto quel senso di
responsabilità individuale che ci deve
porre rispetto alle sfide che abbiamo
col giusto atteggiamento e approccio
Cioè quel senso di responsabilità
nell'essere concentrati per rendere
nostro quello che facciamo dal gesto più
semplice al gesto più complesso con
l'idea di renderli facili e
automatici qualcosa di semplice è
definibile
oggettivamente cosa lo rende facile sono
le nostre abilità oppure il tempo che
dedichiamo alla ripetizione di quel
gesto aprire o chiudere una portiera di
una macchina è un gesto semplice farlo
con un braccio ingessato diventa
difficile far rimbalzare un pallone a
terra è un gesto semplice è anche facile
farlo correndo veloce con i cambi di
direzione con un avversario davanti
diventa difficile e
complesso le scelte difficili e
importanti rispetto al tema ambiente per
adesso le lasciamo a chi occupa il ruolo
di prendere quelle decisioni Noi siamo
anche fortunati Perché i gesti
quotidiani quelli che possono anche fare
la differenza sono perlop
semplici spegnere l'acqua durante mentre
ci laviamo i denti o mentre ci
insaponiamo sotto la doccia fare la
raccolta differenziata questo
tenere le Strade Pulite pensate che nel
2023 ad oggi ci sono ancora persone che
buttano le sigarette per terra spero di
no ma potrebbero essere tra noi A tal
proposito vi racconto un episodio che è
successo a me a mia moglie nostra figlia
Cecilia Stava tornando da scuola aveva
12 anni e davanti a lei una signora ha
buttato una sigaretta per terra Cecilia
con grande coraggio per l'età gli ha
detto Signora Le è caduta una sigaretta
no Tesoro non mi è caduta le ha risposto
e Cecilia Eh infatti la signora
borbottando qualcosa la raccolta e l'ha
messa nel cestino Quindi si può imparare
Si può migliorare è solo una questione
di
abitudini io non ho frequentato il liceo
e non ho studiato latino però mi è stato
detto che abitudini deriva da abitus
cioè l'abito che noi vogliamo fare
indossare al nostro
cervello quando impariamo qualcosa c'è
sempre qualcuno che ce la insegna Quando
ho iniziato a giocare a pallacanestro mi
hanno insegnato che per tirare devi
tenere i piedi alla Larghezza delle
spalle Piega le gambe tieni la schiena
dritta rilassa le spalle allarga bene le
dita sul pallone carica il polso piega
il gomito stendilo davanti alla testa e
via dicendo e ti eserciti e fai c'è
sempre l'allenatore che ti consiglia che
ti corregge deve arrivare un punto però
parlando di responsabilità individuale
che ad ogni singolo gesto sono io che mi
ripeto nella testa per rendere mio quel
movimento che Ok Teo piedi all Larghezza
delle spalle Piega le gambe tieni la
schiena dritta e via dicendo Fate conto
che in un allenamento normale di
pallacanestro si tirano
300-400 tiri mettete assieme tutti gli
allenamenti di una carriera quante volte
tiriamo per alzata di mano Quanti di voi
hanno la
patente praticamente tutti ilel 2023 si
spera vi ricordate la prima volta che
avete guidato a scuola
guida Io mi ricordo e per la
disperazione avevo le mani nelle
sopracciglia perché sali in macchina la
cintura gli specchietti le luci i
semafori i segnali stradali Le Rotonde
gli incroci le biciclette i pedoni le
macchine piove c'è il sole coordina mani
piedi ma dove vado Poi per fortuna
abbiamo il nostro allenatore in macchina
che è l'istruttore di guida che ci
tranquillizza che ci
indica
sono convinto ovviamente che per guidare
serve una caratteristica che dobbiamo
essere concentrati cioè noi siamo
obbligati ad esserlo perché è talmente
complesso perlomeno all'inizio è
talmente pericoloso sempre che se non
siamo concentrati rischiamo di andare a
sbattere ci facciamo del male Peggio
ancora facciamo del male a qualcun
altro sono abbastanza Certo che oggi mi
ci metto dentro anch'io mentre guidate
potete mangiare bere guardare il
cellulare impostare il navigatore
guardare fuori il panorama cercare nella
borsetta nel borsello tutte cose
ripetiamo insieme che non si fanno ma
siamo stati talmente tanto concentrati
in quello che abbiamo fatto che adesso
possiamo pensare e fare dell'altro
mentre eseguiamo un compito così
pericoloso e il nostro allenatore in
macchina non c'è più perché l'istruttore
è sceso già da un bel po' di
tempo Io credo sia giusto avere questo
tipo di approccio in tutte le cose che
facciamo quotidianamente con l'obiettivo
di render le nostre dalle cose più
semplici a quelle più complesse con
l'obiettivo di renderli facili qualcosa
di semplice è definibile oggettivamente
Ok l'abbiamo detto prima quindi quello
che possiamo fare è renderlo
facile m Perché i gesti che possono fare
la differenza sono
importanti all'interno del mio percorso
con la palla spicchi mi è sempre
piaciuto tantissimo allenarmi tanto e
forte però ho attraversato tre momenti
diversi di
consapevolezza quando ero piccolino mi
allenavo forte tanto perché mi dicevano
di farlo Quando ho iniziato un po' a
crescere mi allenavo tanto e forte
perché altrimenti mi sentivo in colpa se
non lo
facevo ho raggiunto la consapevolezza
finale la maturità quando mi allenavo
tanto e forte perché lo trovavo giusto
per me e per quelli che avevo
accanto noi quotidianamente possiamo
avere le nostre motivazioni per fare
quello che facciamo per me non conta non
ce n'è una migliore peggiore dell'altra
per essere virtuosi non vogliamo essere
virtuosi per il cambiamento climatico
facciamolo almeno per l'impatto
inquinante dei nostri gesti quotidiani
non vogliamo farlo per l'impatto
inquinante facciamolo per quanto è
brutto vedere le strade sporche
l'ambiente sporco non vogliamo farlo per
l'impatto visivo facciamolo per le
generazioni che verranno non vogliamo
farlo per i nostri figli facciamoci
curare però a questo
punto da oggi mentre il tempo
inesorabilmente sta
scorrendo proviamo a pensare a quello
che possiamo fare proviamo a capire che
abito far indossare al nostro cervello
dimostriamo a noi
di essere delle persone Clutch proviamo
a rendere facile anche quello che oggi è
già
semplice
[Applauso]
Grazie